is crucial that the EU does not supply
or help the goods or services that could
lead to the death penalty or torture
Europe's lead in technological
innovation can be a double-edged sword
when it comes to tools and services
exported to countries which torture and
kill their citizens human rights
organizations say torture continues in
half of the hundred and fifty eight
countries that ratified a convention
banning it and the global trade in tools
used for it is booming the space for
civil society the democratic countries
in the world are shrinking we've just
seen that press freedom worldwide is
also diminishing and so we as
representatives in open societies and
democracies have to be very vigilant EU
law binding on all Member States was
agreed in 2005 but despite changes since
many loopholes remain now Parliament
urged by civil society bodies is seeking
to tighten those we are seeking to limit
the export of very blatant tools that
are used for for torture such as
changing people or beating people but
also medicines that could be used to
give a lethal injection for example
should not be sold to prisons or law
enforcement agencies there is evidence
that existing legislation works it's
been reported to parliament from the USA
that the ban on medical substances that
can be used for executions there has
made them more difficult to perform